- [Voiceover] How do we count the flowers?
So, this first choice,
they go one, two, three,
and then they don't count
this one and then they skip it
and they go four, five, six,
and then they skip this one again,
and then they say seven, eight.
That's not how you count flowers!
You'd say this is four, this is five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10.
So, this first choice is not right.
Now, the second one looks better.
One, two, three, four,
they didn't skip this one,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
That one looks good so
I'll click right over here
and check my answer.
How do we count the mice?
Let's see, one, two, this
isn't the third mouse!
This is the second mouse!
This is crazy, this isn't right.
All right, this one over here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, this is right.
Up here they skipped the number two,
this should be the second
mouse, not the third mouse!
All right.
Let's keep going.
Type the missing numbers.
It says count the ladybugs.
Type the missing numbers in the boxes.
All right, this is ladybug number one.
Two, then let me type three,
then let me type four.
It's a lot of fun.
Count the flowers.
Type the missing numbers in the boxes.
This is flower number
one, flower number two.
Just gonna type that right in there.
Check it, lemme do one more.
How do we count the flowers?
So, we saw one like this
a few questions ago.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10.
That one looks good.
This one, just like the
last time, they skipped,
actually they skipped the same ones.
This wouldn't be the right way to do it.
So, we select this one right
here, and then we're done.